después de los partidos de Panamá los
más concurridos fueron los de Nicaragua
muchos nicaragüenses se dijeron
presentes en el juego final del torneo
en el que su selección derrotó tres por
uno a Brasil el lanzador osman Gutiérrez
fue fundamental en el triunfo
centroamericano permitió tres hits
ponchó a 5 y la única carrera que
concedió fue por error y Nicaragua logra
clasificar por primera vez al clásico
Mundial de Béisbol mientras Panamá
países de estas eliminatorias se vuelve
luego de haber dicho presente en las
ediciones del 2006 y 2009 serán en total
20 países que saltarán al diamante en el
torneo mundialista de béisbol en 2023 8
son representantes latinoamericanos
Colombia Cuba México Nicaragua República
Dominicana Puerto Rico Panamá y
Venezuela este torneo ha sido dominado
por los japoneses que han conquistado el
Campeonato en dos de las cuatro
ediciones dis